now tonight we are witnessing a White
House in full crisis mode they are
panicking In The West Wing tonight Biden
visibly shaken after the appointment of
a special counsel to investigate the
classified top secret obama-era
documents that recently quote turned up
at three now separate unsecured
locations that includes Joe Biden's
Garage in Delaware next to his vintage
Corvette but don't worry the garage was
locked at least most of the time take a
look there's the garage right there
anyway the Scandal gets worse by the day
now coming up we'll take you through a
shocking timeline that is very damning
for both Joe Biden and the Department of
Justice his Department of Justice will
follow the money all the way back to
China and also back again and we have a
special report breaking news just about
10 minutes ago from John Solomon also
tonight the great one Mark Levin he will
weigh in on all of this Geraldo will be
in the Hannity Hot Seat tonight to offer
his defense of his good friend Joe Biden
well frankly there is no defense former
Intel chairman also Devin Nunes he will
join us tonight with reaction to What
was released today the latest batch of
Twitter files that directly involves the
former chairman and Adam Schiff and
everybody in between and it will prove
that we were Vindicated on all of our
reporting as it relates to the Russia
hoax but let's begin tonight in
Wilmington Delaware at Joe Biden's
longtime private residence now for more
than two decades Joe Jill even Hunter
have called this house a home but as it
turns out Biden's Mansion also was
housing numerous classified top secret
documents from his time as vice
president that he apparently stole from
the Obama White House when he left in
early 2017. now the documents were
recently located in Biden's personal
Library even his garage again take a
look at the picture uh wide open he said
well the door was locked not all the
time apparently said that in a 2020
campaign video now presumably the
documents were located in those
cardboard boxes pictured right there but
according to Joe Biden it's not a big
deal because people know he takes
classified materials seriously really
take a look
classified material next to your
Corvette what were you thinking
let me uh we're going to get a chance to
speak on all this God willing soon but
as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvettes in a
lock garage okay so it's not like you're
sitting out in the street but anyway
yes as well as my Corvette
um but as I said earlier this week
people know I take classified documents
and classified materials seriously okay
that's laughable people that take
classified materials seriously they
don't stash secret documents in a garage
for years a private garage that has been
accessed by oh one guy named Hunter
Biden and God knows who else now during
Joe Biden's four years as a private
citizen and then during his many visits
as presidents we have no idea at this
time who entered that house there are no
visitor logs no security logs nothing
they've been hiding that for two years
from the American people since he's been
president according to a visibly nervous
Kareen Jean-Pierre the Biden White House
is the most transparent Administration
in history I think not but that's their
claim take a look
when will the White House release a log
of visitors to the Wilmington House you
know
Peter you've asked this question or is
your colleagues I've asked this question
before let's not forget
what we did here in this white house we
instituted something that the last
Administration got rid of which is
putting out the white house uh putting
making sure that there was a White House
law extensive White House log so the
American people got to see the house
again again unsecured classified
material again I am telling you we did
something that the last Administration
got rid of which is instituting the
White House logs uh did you ask the last
Administration why they got rid of the
White House law okay
go ahead thank you go ahead we have the
records from the Delaware residents oh
I'm sorry I was calling the gentleman
who wanted to ask a question that was
not related to this
that's not true because 40 of his time
as president has been outside of the
White House and they have never released
any of the visitor logs now the Biden
White House cares so much about
transparency they attempted to hide this
classified document Scandal now for
months and for a while Biden's doj
that's right his doj from the executive
branch his executive branch we're more
than happy to oblige let's take a look
at this timeline let's start last August
after president Trump invited Federal
officials to his home to review
presidential documents they went in the
very room where they later found
documents during a raid they had it that
day they could have taken it with them
that day they called and said would you
put a padlock on the room that we went
into where these quote documents existed
that request was granted they put a
padlock on it the FBI then instead of
just knocking on the door and saying can
we go back in the room no they raided
Mar-A-Lago They seized the documents by
4 course they had unfettered access
previously in that room no need for that
in September Biden berated former
president Trump called them
irresponsible on 60 Minutes then
November 2nd six days before the
all-important midterms a trove of top
secret classified documents they were
found in Biden's private office and the
doj was notified then there was no
subsequent raid at Biden's private
offices or home and Biden and Garland
and Biden's doj said nothing to you the
American people information you should
have had before the election two weeks
later November 18th Mary Garland
appoints a special counsel to only
investigate Donald Trump not Joe Biden
it wasn't until today that Garland
appointed a special counsel to
investigate Biden now the White House
continues to claim that the president
had no idea classified documents were
housed in multiple unsecured locations
by the way Donald Trump as we pointed
out yesterday he had every right to
decay classify there's no set process
there's no legal process or means that
he has to follow that is not something a
vice president has as Jonathan Turley
points out the claim is probably a
bold-faced life at least some of those
documents were moved multiple times so
we'll find out in time that's because
the UPenn Biden Center where much of the
materials quote turned up didn't open
their doors until 2018. so that means
over a year after Biden left the Obama
White House so where were the documents
stored before then and who moved them
around and who might have saw them now
speaking of which the UPenn political
Center named after Joe Biden was
probably one of the worst places on
Earth to store a top secret document
according to these new reports tonight
from John Solomon the University of
Pennsylvania get this pay very close
attention to the money they collected a
whopping 67 million dollars between 2013
and 2019 from a vast majority of that
money nearly 50 million dollars 47.7
million flowed in during Biden's
lucrative Reign at the UPenn Biden
Center and get this in a 2016 email
uncovered on the very real laptop of
Hunter Biden Hunter's agent references
the creation of the UPenn Center while
also discussing Hunter's plans for
wealth creation now keep in mind
Hunter's laptop also revealed a plan for
the Biden's to share office space at the
UPenn Biden center with individuals from
the Chinese Communist party in one email
there was even a request to get keys
made for these Chinese Nationals now
remember just prior to this Hunter was
ranking in millions and millions of
dollars from Chinese foreign Nationals
including proceeds from the
multi-billion Dollar Deal Inc with the
Bank of China 10 days after Hunter
joined his father the vice president on
that trip to Beijing on Air Force two
and of course another massive deal with
the Chinese energy conglomerate don't
forget the the five million dollar no
interest forgivable loan don't forget
the hundred thousand dollars Chinese
National shopping spree if all of this
isn't damning enough in February of 2022
after getting millions of donations from
China the University of Pennsylvania
successfully lobbied the Biden justice
department to end a counter Espionage
program against beijing's growing
influence over Academia A.G Garland
ended the program in February of 2022.
keep in mind China is our country
America's number one geopolitical Foe
and now the chairman of the house
oversight committee James Comer he is
tonight calling for deeper
investigations into Biden's special
relationship with China take a look
they encouraged the Pennsylvania where
his Biden Center is where all the
Chinese money goes to fund all these
Biden initiatives they encourage the FBI
to drop that
China initiative investigation
what else are they influencing uh this
Administration to do what else is China
influencing this Administration and the
Biden family I mean this is very
concerning so we're sending a letter to
Penn requesting documents related to the
Chinese donations we want a list of
individuals involved whoever was
involved in soliciting donations from
China we want all Communications
all right so the fact that top secret
classified compartmented documents were
discovered in the UPenn Biden Center is
more than a little strange the fact that
Hunter Biden could have easily accessed
all those documents is more than a
little concerning and the fact that we
have no idea how many classified
documents remain in Biden's house garage
office is beyond troubling to say the
least the fact that China Russia Ukraine
and a multitude of other countries paid
Hunter and the family Syndicate Millions
without any experience uh is beyond
anybody's imagination and by the way we
need answers because it was Joe Biden
himself I never once talked to Hunter
about my foreign business dealings mayor
Garland Chris Ray there's really only
one way to know if all the classified
material has been turned over to you and
you know what it is don't you I'll give
you a hint you had no problem doing this
at Mar-A-Lago now if this is really a
serious investigation it is time for all
of Biden's private properties to be
rated probably tomorrow morning would be
a good time and searched otherwise our
two-tiered system of justice will have
reared its ugly head yet again and the
investigations by Jordan and calmer now
take on massive new urgency hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else